(gentle instrumental music)
- When you find a tree
that has an apple in it
and just discovering new varieties.
It's just, I mean, I live for that.
I'm Andy Brennan.
My wife and I, we around our town
and we forage for wild apples
and we make it into a series of ciders
based on where the apples are located.
- [Man] You sell
at the Gramercy Tavern?
- Yeah, yeah Gramercy Tavern, um,
which I've only eaten at once.
I know it's famous and
especially their wine menu
is somewhat famous.
- Having cider made
from wild-foraged fruit
is really unusual, something
that can only be done
in very small amounts.
What comes out of the
bottle is really special.
- We go out into the woods.
We go to places where apples
are not at all influenced
by human cultivation.
We're searching the woods
and sometimes it's difficult
to find the trees.
And If the light doesn't hit the
silver in the trunk just right,
you may not even know it's an apple tree.
You're in luck when you
find not just one or two,
but a whole forest of trees
which sometimes does exist.
What I love is discovering varieties
that are just so peculiar.
You would never find
'em in a grocery store.
The other day we found an apple
that has red flesh, so you bite into it
and it just looks like a pomegranate.
They're telling us, "Process."
It takes about four hours to grind
and press enough juice to fill a barrel.
I think of those barrels as bears.
It's hibernating.
Nine months after you
collected the apples,
that's when it's ready.